Harlequin  [Music]  before she ran off and joined the circus  she was known as dr. Harleen Quinzel  psychiatrist at Arkham Asylum she was  assigned to the clown in itself dr.  Quinzel and I live for these moments  with you very yeah that's your kitty so  thoughtful she thought she was curing  him but she was falling in love there is  something you could do for me doctor  how do you think I mean yeah I need a  machine gun  a machine gun talk about a workplace  where a man's gone wrong  why do we have years what are you gonna  do you're gonna kill me mr. J what oh  I'm not gonna kill you I'm just gonna  hurt you  really really bad  you think so well I can take it  they became the king and queen of Gotham  City and God help anyone who  disrespected the Queen  you